Putin sees this not simply as the future
of Ukraine which is Russia's most
important neighbor but in many ways I
think I I really believe you see this in
some ways as the future of Russia he in
no way wants the liberal virus to infect
Ukraine because his fear would be that
obviously it would become a
demonstration effect for his own country
right I am fascinated by this a little
bit off script but with a Russian fleet
in the Black Sea off of Odessa and the
rest of southern Ukraine how does
America and how does Europe respond to
that I mean it's become literally a
naval action as well hasn't it there's
not a lot the US and Europe can do
because normally we would provide all
sorts of economic help but only with
strings attached people are not going to
provide 10 15 20 billion dollars of help
without certain types of political and
economic condition allottee that's
exactly what Yanukovych is not going to
agree to when he went he's under siege
so in a funny sort of way our hands are
tied because we don't want to throw good
money after a bad situation so we almost
have to see where things come out if he
basically prevails then we could
introduce can help with conditionality
or if there's a new government we could
provide an awful lot of help invested
our house when is this move from an
uprising into a civil war what has to
happen well then it's simply a question
of what it grows you had the first
serious show of force by the government
in the last 24 hours whenever things
like have to happen like this whether
you're talking about Syria all the
places in the Middle East or quite
honestly Paris in the middle of the 19th
century it's now a battle of nerve the
question is does the government and the
security forces keep its nerve all the
protesters prepared to continue to put
their lives in jeopardy in the hopes of
overthrowing the the government so you
know that's that's the dynamic now
ambassador Haase Vice President Biden
called President Yanukovych last night
asked for for him in effect to a
de-escalate instead we find out that 25
people are killed overnight what do you
think the likely next series of events
be over the safe 48 hours I would expect
you to have more of the same the u.s.
can call for for restraint but we don't
have ways to either enforce it or
terribly well to to incentivize it I
think the critical dynamic now is is
essentially will the government and the
security forces remain willing to kill
their own people if that's what it takes
if they are Richard a regime is likely
to survive Richard we are a long way
from secretary Kissinger classic
diplomacy then we go on to the
Washington Consensus and then I don't
know what the new foreign policy is
within the theory of what you do with
the Council on Foreign Relations what
should be America's international
relations when we seal when we feel so
useless with the Ukraine well more
broadly I would say you know two things
one is you got the president going to to
Mexico today but it's against the
backdrop of no movement at home on
immigration and increasing questions
over whether we could ever give him the
trade promotion Authority he will need
to negotiate trade Accords so the
biggest foreign policy challenge
continues to be the domestic calm and
then secondly I would say the United
States has been overly invested in the
Middle East we haven't been paying
attention enough to events in Asia
including Thailand meanwhile you've got
things like Ukraine and then as well as
spinning out of control so I would
simply say we need to rebalance our farm
policy away from this over fascination
and emphasis on the Middle East and take
into account more Asia in the rest of
the world very quickly are Richard where
should we look in Europe for leadership
they won't take miracles phone call
which institution in Europe will get
this done Tom Europe and leadership we
are borderline oxymoron I mean you've
got institutions like the OECD and
others to deal with the security thing
but the bottom line is you don't have
Europe as a collective entity when it
comes to being a foreign policy actor so
the answer is you can't look to Europe
for her leadership which is one of the
advantages that Putin has he's a single
lone operator he makes decisions Europe
does not have that kind of a capacity